good citizens of the reject nation in honor
of Namor the Submariner entering the MCU and
in honor of many many comments on these videos
it is time to rank all of the villains in the
MCU all of them that said we are going to
be ranking the main villains in the ncu a
couple supporting but overall we went through
all the movies phase one through four all of
the shows phase one through four and looked at
who the villains were so no there are certain
supporting characters that did not make the cut
I understand I couldn't get to all of them I
think it's 529 on Marvel Wiki but the Lion
Share the big one there's 63 in here we're
gonna go through every single villain ranked
by my experience with them let's get into it
coming in at number 63 the worst in my opinion
villain in the MCU is yonrog this is because I
feel like it was meant to be a Twist and it didn't
feel like a Twist I feel like it was one of the
rare times in the greater MCU that they were like
I got you and I was like I didn't felt a little uh
I don't know it felt mustache twirly and it felt
like it was a little bit assuming of ignorance on
on the behalf of the filmmakers to the audience
I did feel like it was like trying to assume we
were a little dumber than we were and I felt a
little uh underwhelmed by it so some of these are
lower because they were a bit boring or one note
this one is the lowest because it both felt a bit
one note but also felt like uh it was assuming
I was dumber than I am and that was a little
assault things nothing against Jude Law I think
that he had a lot of fun playing it and I'm happy
for him it just did not work for me and it felt
like it judged me 62 is Taskmaster now overall I
like the black widow movie quite a bit more than
I think the average I had a great time with it I
really enjoyed the overall experience and I loved
especially the fighting and all of those elements
that felt very Jason Bourne I love that Scarlett
finally got to play Black Widow in her own movie
I really enjoyed Florence Pew getting introduced
there's so many things on the movie I like what
I didn't like was the way they undermined
what taskmaster's powers are I don't mind
that Taskmaster is a woman in this continuity
I don't mind that Taskmaster came from the Red
Room and has ties to Black Widow what I do mind
is by making her mute by making her someone whose
powers are programmed you lose the character of
Taskmaster the character of Taskmaster is someone
who can mirror someone by watching them that
can basically have the almost mutant ability to
replicate something that's a really cool unique
ability that's then kind of aized a iodized AIS
and they also make it so the fun of Taskmaster
is the playful banter the the mercenary aspect
the fact that you don't know who Taskmaster is
going to side with the duplicitousness all of
the things that make Taskmaster cool the skull and
the smarm are gone if you make the skull kind of
a a motorcycle helmet you get rid of literally
the smarm in the dialogue and you make it so
the powers are negated so the things that make
characters cool are appearance powers and and all
the things that they took away from Taskmaster
so I like the the Red Room twist didn't really
like the rest number 61 is Aldrich Killian now
this one is especially interesting because Iron
Man 3 is one of my favorite MCU films in my top
third and I think before the big Studio note
this might have been a fun play on the character
because originally it was supposed to be a Rebecca
Ferguson as the big villain but like promoter who
was running things at the time wanted to sell more
toys thought men sold more toys made the villain
basically Ultra Killian feels like very last
minute this feels like a studio note of a villain
so you've got a thing that feels very paper thin
you've got a very mustache twirling Choice you've
got a lot of things that would be fun if it was a
mislead like the other misleading in the movie
we'll get to the Mandarin a little bit but the
mislead here doesn't work because it's like we've
got all these misleading land on and he's the bad
guy so it's like we had the opportunity to have
something really special and then because of third
act notes it fell apart and also for some reason
he could breathe fire I that didn't work for me
so uh he's gonna be lower he is 61 Ultra Killian
love me some guy Pierce just not here number 60
coming in on the lower side and this is one of the
more controversial ones because it bums me out and
this is the one that I think is most expectation
versus delivery and I gotta say he's lower than a
lot of the ones that I'm just neutral towards
because of my high expectations one of my top
10 Marvel villains in the overall adaptation of
Marvel Comics ever is Kingpin one of my bottom
five in the MCU is Kingpin I love love Vincent
d'onofrio's Kingpin I love what he does with
this character I love how he's utilized I love how
much he loves his City I love that he feels like
an exact mirror of Daredevil I love that you're
rooting for him almost as much as Daredevil and
how that makes you feel as a person I got none of
that from the Hawkeye portrayal I got a very very
um comic book in a bad way kind of thin narrative
where it's like he big guy he throw he powers and
it didn't feel like it was the same character and
I know we haven't really addressed whether or not
they're gonna be the same character in Canon yet
there's been a lot of interviews a lot of talks
off camera but whereas I feel like Daredevil
really worked on She-Hulk by using like some
of the charm and the playfulness and all those
things to make him work in a different medium and
a different genre that didn't land with Kingpin
it felt like a different character even though
it was the same actor it felt like they didn't
let him play the Kingpin it felt like he was
doing a more of a Saturday morning cartoon and
the thing I love about Kingpin is he's not that
portrayal so I'm very excited to see him in Echo
I'm very excited to see Vincent D'Onofrio going
forward unfortunately the portrayal in Hawkeye
AI left a lot to be desired for me 59 is malekith
now malakith is probably a lot of people's number
one worst he's the lowest uh for a lot of people
because they didn't really give Chris Eccleston
a lot to do uh he's one of the dark elves in the
comics that is is maniacal and dark and has a lot
of texture and a lot of things playing with light
and darkness his face is literally splitting
two with light and dark and there's a lot of
Injustice in how he sees things here he's a bad
guy that does bad guy things there's not really
a lot of subplot for why he loves Darkness boy
just likes Darkness so uh this one didn't work
for me because it just felt like they didn't give
him a lot of writing to play with and uh Chris
Eccleston is a fantastic actor I would have loved
to see play Malachi in another opportunity maybe
in an else World maybe you know what if number 58
is likewise another incredible actor in another
part that I would love to see expanded with maybe
a bit more and I also love certain elements of
this portrayal it's just some of these got to be
low because others are high and that is casilius
I personally love the idea of someone being a
religious zealot that is overwhelmed with this
sense of right that takes them over and honestly
I think the two major attempts at it haven't quite
landed for me three now with Moon Knight but the
three major attempts they have varying degrees of
success out of those I think this is the lowest
success for me because I never really felt
the passion I felt the idea of the passion
I felt it in the dialogue more than the the
delivery and it's not an acting Choice it's just
like there was so much going on in a movie where
you got to introduce magic into the MCU I love
what Scott Derrickson did with the tone I love
what Scott Derrickson did with the World building
I loved all those things but I felt like because
there was so much else going on casillius got
shortchanged and I don't really remember what
his motivation was he hated Tilda Swinton for
being a hypocrite that's all I really remember
and that's not quite enough for me for a character
that could have been so much number 57 is laufi
this is the frost giant father of Loki I wasn't
even sure whether to include him or not he felt
like more of a bait and switch of a villain but
with laufi in a character that is so terrifying
that he sometimes intimidates the gods I just
feel like I don't remember him strongly enough
even after re-watching these films to have
that be delivered as laughy now this is very
early on in the MCU I don't fault it as much as
others that's why I mean I consider laufi worse
as you know an intimidation Factor than say the
Kingpin but because I don't really remember it
because it didn't leave an impact it's a little
higher because expectations were lower but it's
just kind of a you know fluffy was there number
56 the power broker so this one's interesting
because I wanted to feel the oomph of a reveal
and I really think that the tone of this show had
a lot of elements that felt like Espionage that
felt like there was going to be a big twist that
felt like Falcon the Winter Soldier was going to
end with something that was like gobsmacking and
I felt like they just maybe planted too many seeds
they gave us too many hints at that the fact that
we were going to be betrayed by agent 13 that we
were going to get this this moment of like ah so
I I a little bit felt like maybe the tone was too
shoehorned in so this is a show that got a lot of
rewrites because of kovid this is a show that
had to reframe a lot of their things and maybe
that caused this to be a little too on the nose
but I do feel like the power broker reveal kind
of undermined the impact of how I wanted this
villain to land number 55 is The Sovereign now
this is a set of characters that I'm hoping and
get some time to improve with guardians 3 but
with Guardians 2 doing a lot with ego and having
you know all those characters in The Guardians
already I do feel like The Sovereign felt like
an addition in World building and an abstraction
versus an actual threat I never was really worried
for her characters with the Sovereign as cool as
they were and as much as I love their imagery
and as much as I love the casting I really hope
it's it's going to be more of a setting up Adam
Warlock and then we find more about this however
and it does feel like the the part one of two
of the sovereigns that's why you know I'm not
really sure how to put these as villains but when
I think of the villain of Guardians 2 I've got ego
in The Sovereign and The Sovereign didn't leave
as much as an impact as I hoped they would hoping
that changes in three number 54 is Curse curse
with a K remember curse curse killed uh you know
Thor's mom Rene Russo is dead because of curse and
that's about all I remember from curse that's not
great that is a secondary villain to malekith and
I guess because the expectations were lower that's
why he's a little higher he had a cool visual
aesthetic but he didn't really get to do a lot but
he gotta count as a villain if you you kill frig
up so uh curse 54. number 53 is Yellow Jacket now
in the MCU especially in the first couple phases
the villain problem was largely making the villain
just the antithesis of the hero which is a logical
thing it's what the comics do it's what works and
what doesn't it's it's interesting because when it
works it really works but when it doesn't it feels
very one note and Corey stole is a very good actor
I love him in the house of cards I love him when
he pops up in in Indies even though he had one
of the most graphic and intense murders in the
MCU he literally turns a guy into like Splat and
throws him away I didn't ever feel any more of a
threat I never felt like Ant-Man had anything
to go against him other than just like that's
bad Ant-Man and yellow jacket so this villain
didn't quite work for me because I just didn't
know what his plot was beyond being the antithesis
number 52 are the chatari the chachari in general
now groups of villains are tricky because how
much can you really invest this was tricky to
even include because I do feel like they are the
villains in Avengers and they are set up beautiful
in certain post-credit scenes but I never really
knew other than them being kind of like worker
bees for Loki what their goals were so the chatari
had cool visual design I love the different ships
I love the organic nature of the ships that's why
they're higher but I never really got to know what
the Qatari would want and I always thought they
were kind of a parallel to the brood like when
they didn't have the fox licensing at Marvel I
felt like the chittari could have gone brewed
they could have come back they could have done
a lot more and it's been cool to see their their
weaponry and stuff come back and be utilized and
maybe we'll still get more of the races of space
what these other species are what their goals are
did they want to invade us to take over our planet
Etc I just didn't really get that from the chatari
so they're 52. number 51 is the Destroyer Thor one
had a lot to do where we had already brought in
Iron Man Who is our most maybe approachable not
in personality but in like a guy builds a suit and
then Captain America we've got adventure movies
we've got Nostalgia Thor had to be like hey we
got those things we're gonna add in magic but only
Norse magic you're going to believe in all this
mythology and you're going to do all of that with
this awesome handsome new guy Chris Hemsworth it's
doing a lot so Loki is pretty much the antagonist
but he's kind of the antagonist fall phase one so
the actual antagonist doesn't get a lot to do so
Destroyer gets a big old pass because he's just
really cool looking and he's the puppet on the
string and he does that very well I mean is a big
destroying thing so Destroyer 51 all right Top 50.
This is a long list number 50 is whiplash remember
his bird he just wanted that bird real bad he
was a product of Iron Man 2 feeling rushed I mean
Mickey Rourke was coming off of the wrestler his
big comeback jumped on a Marvel movie all the
ingredients were there but I feel like we didn't
really have much in the way of the Vengeance that
was implied like there was a lot of Revenge that
was shown on screen but I never really felt it
like when you get later on to Winter Soldier
and that revenge in the other direction from
Tony towards something that's earned and felt
I never really felt a lot from this villain that
felt you know a bit more on the Saturday morning
cartoon side and I think it was a mix of the rush
production uh you know a difference of ideas of
portrayal making sure we juggle all these things
and setting up Iron Man 2 is definitely stuck and
you've got to set a lot of stuff up problem so I
think this was just an early misstep for Marvel
which they then did quickly Rectify number 49 the
black order now this is another group of villains
this is thanos's Posse and the reason it's so
low is I think they just didn't get the time to
really be anything but a posse group of villains
that work for villains henchmen don't really get
to do a lot they're a little higher than others
because there was some moments of characterization
there was a little emotional impact there was
some really cool visual choices and Designs
but again this is a list of 63 something's got
to be lower when you've got this many villains
the ones that fall into the background around
Thanos are just inevitably at 49. number 48 and
this one is hard to categorize because it almost
doesn't feel fair in a show that's dealing with
cliches and is very intentionally going like
this is bad writing because we did this to you
know make sure the audience feels this in these
certain things it's hard to judge any villains
but in looking back at my experience of Shield
I did find I never believed what Titania wanted
besides the joke of social media so I definitely
had moments where I was like man that's too real
and social media definitely impacts me like that
and man doing it for the gram and all those things
but I would have loved beyond that one moment
at the wedding of her having a real moment if
she's gonna be the main antagonist which like
I said she didn't end up being it would have
been nice to see a little bit more of that it
wasn't Jamila Jamil's performance and it wasn't
even necessarily the writing it was the fact that
she was much like the black order a side thing to
the main villain so she's on this list it's low
just because I didn't really know where else to
categorize a villain that's kind of intentionally
a distraction from the real problem number 47
is lizard we've got five villains in Spider-Man
no way home amongst those I feel like the one that
didn't get the most time is gonna be the lowest
uh lizard got a few moments to shine got some
good jokes but overall like lizard's just kind
of lizard it's cool to see a little Redemption
for Risa fawns getting to come back from the
amazing franchise but at the same time when you've
got five villains one of them's gotta not have as
strong of an arc and turning everyone into lizards
just like the comics is a bit silly so hard to add
a lot of pathos to that and thus 47 lizard number
46 is drakov from Black Widow it is hard to keep
moving forward with the MCU and have villains that
are both getting the right amount of time but also
delivering really strong messages the messaging in
Black Widow almost didn't need a central villain
it needed someone just pull the strings the abuse
of women is staggering and awful and real someone
just had to be the face of that because of that
you didn't need a lot of screen time but because
of that lack of screen time when he showed up it
was hard to feel anything except for hate that guy
and in a world as profoundly in-depth as the MCU
when they just hate that guy shows up it's not
going to be as high as other villains so this
character really just suffered from the theme was
more of the villain than the villain himself so
when I say 46 Drake off is Adam Winstone it's Adam
Winstone good old Adam Winstone Ray Winstone when
I say Ray Winstone this low it's more just the the
theme worked more than the the personification of
the theme for me not good not bad 46 Ray Winstone
number 45 razor fist this is ironically a huge
step up from the characterization of whiplash this
is a very similar character if you look at it it's
got these two things wields them cool fights but
here I feel like they used the henchmen thing
better like I think of whiplash was a henchman it
would have worked if they did the Thunderbolts and
they brought back Whiplash that'd be cool because
it's a really cool visual thing but he's not like
a main villain which is why the other villain of
Iron Man 2 is higher we'll get to that later but
that villain great the villain here he's got
really cool choreography he's got really cool
elements to him and he's only kind of for that
purpose that said can't be much higher because
what I love about the villains is when they've
got as much to do as the hero obviously Razer
fist didn't get an opportunity but I gotta give
him credit for being this high with just a guy
with razor fists I mean full credit where credit
is due now we're getting into the villains that
I feel stronger about but didn't feel like they
got to do quite as much as they needed to to be
in the top third so we're about halfway through
this list and this is where they start getting
good but for something or the other just didn't
work out for me and that's going to bring us to
number 44 which is najma najma was the villain
in Miss Marvel and this much like the uh Ray
Winstone character a lot of the themes were the
villain like it was generational trauma it was
the looking at family and how family Dynamics
can be toxic or strong and there's a lot of
things there but I feel like with najma it was
introducing so many things like I mean spoiler for
Miss Marvel mutants as well as the veil as well
as introducing her powers as well as setting up
that incredible school as well as setting up her
own son that I didn't know by the time we got to
the delivery of hers the main villain how much
to invest in her so I never really felt enough
for the character to have her much higher as well
as it was portrayed just didn't get to feel a lot
for her directly so when she got you know phased
and evaporated and all that stuff I wanted to feel
more there so it's a little on the Lower Side
number 43 is another of the five villains in
Spider-Man no way home this one's going to Electro
so this one's here because I really think Jamie
Foxx found his Electro in no way home I think
they all did I think all five of the villains
finally got to give the portrayal they had wanted
but I do find that as fun as the portrayal of a
guy that's power hungry that has power of power
like that's fun I love that greed that Electro
had I did struggle with the fact that it was one
line of dialogue of like the air feels different
here so now Jamie Foxx like he just became Jamie
Foxx I enjoyed the power hungry Jamie Foxx but I
would have loved a little bit more about you know
the Multiverse can change you or in this universe
this is my it just it was the one of the times the
Multiverse reversal problem wasn't addressed and I
love no way home if you follow this playlist you
know no way home is my jam that's my number one
but that was the moment where I was like oh this
this multiversal choice is pulling me out of the
suspension of belief so Electro as the thing that
represents that suspension belief is going to be
lower as much as I enjoyed the Betrayal number
42 are the tracksuit Mafia as an entity I am a
huge fan of the matte fraction aha run of Hawkeye
and a huge part of that other tracksuit Mafia my
issue mainly with the tracksuit Mafia is we were
all wanting some big bad that didn't feel like
it delivered for me we talked about that a little
bit at the top of Kingpin but the tracksuit Mafia
then because of that erraticness also felt erratic
they were funny they said bro I got a lot of those
things they are as you may notice one of the
higher groups of villains on here because I did
enjoy that the fact they felt like the comic books
but they couldn't be any higher than 42 for me
because that was their purpose to be henchmen and
henchmen are never in higher top villain lists so
as henchmen good job as top villains air 42 number
41 another of the groups of villains and that
representing a problem and that also goes into
Carly morgenthau herself in Falcon and the Winter
Soldier a troubled production dealing with a virus
plot when the pandemic broke out these characters
I feel like were probably the most Rewritten in
post of anything maybe in the entire MCU these
are characters that we're going to use a virus to
implement their plot and then we were dealing with
a real virus that you know you can't really tell
that story at the time the show came out so I feel
like these characters did not get to pay what they
needed to be I do think it's interesting that we
are living in the MCU that is now processing both
how government and organizations can be flawed in
their power struggle as well as radicals that are
trying to undermine organizations can be flawed
because anytime you've got a power structure
it can go awry so I love the concept of these
flags passers I love the idea of it being
the anti-shield falling apart the anti-hydra
Takeover but they didn't really get the chance
to show that and I don't think it's their but
it's got to be somewhere 41. top 40 and this one
pains me to say because I think he's about to be
a really incredible character in Thunderbolts but
so far I haven't gotten to see General Thunderbolt
Ross get to be General Thunderbolt Ross in the
comic books he's such a main part of why Hulk
is driven towards certain things he's this father
figure that hates what his daughter loves and and
there's the power struggle of government versus
this individual there's the the father-daughter
struggle there's all these things and since we
don't really have Betty Ross in the MCU I feel
like Thunderbolt Ross has had to be a guy that's
just like the representation of military in the
distance and since we've got shield and since
we've got all these other elements I haven't
really known anything of him except the sokovia
chords and that in itself isn't about him so I
think with the Thunderbolts and with Harrison
Ford we might see a lot more of Thunderbolt
Roth that might completely change where he is
but right now because I don't really know what
he represents in the MCU he's just kind of there
I like the portrayal number 40 Thunderbolt Ross
number 39 is our guy guy that represents the evil
Superman and this worked for me more than most
eternals works for me more than most but at the
same time it's odd if eternals was a mini-series
if it was one of the shows and we got six hours
with it I feel like Icarus would be very high
I feel like what Richard Madden did with this
portrayal I really enjoyed I felt the Betrayal
I felt his Nuance I felt where he was coming from
I felt all of those things but when I think back
on the movie I think of the overall theme of uh
wanting to feel seen and wanting to understand
where I stand in the universe and what we all
represent as beings uh shaping the universe all
those things more than I feel what his choices
were to represent the eternals so by by nature
of what the story that had to be told Icarus is
on the lower side as much as I really really loved
it he's a highlight for me but now we're into the
stuff that I really enjoy that just if this was a
mini series man what Icarus could have been number
38 is sandman I love me a reluctant hero I love
mirror reluctant villain with Sandman he's never
really against Spider-Man I love that throughout
no way homies just distrustful I love that he's
got to do a lot I love personally as someone Who
Loved These Sandman elements of Spider-Man 3 that
we got more time with him but he's kind of just
the guy that's reluctant like we don't because
of the movie juggling three Spider-Man and five
villains we don't get to really feel that moment
like we do in Spider-Man 3 where he's like trying
to put himself back together in the swirling that
moment represents both his mental and physical
disarray and I feel like we didn't get a lot of
Thomas Hayden Church getting to play with that
so uh because of that he's on the lower side
I love this portrayal I think it's one of the
better castings I think Thomas Hayden Church is
sandman it was great to see him again but it's
just I wanted more 38 number 37 I said there were
going to be more religious zealots on this list
the second of those three is Ronan the Accuser
I really like the idea of the cree being these
passionate zealots it sets up the cree scroll War
really well I think what they were able to do with
his voice and his presence and all those things
was pretty powerful and I do think it served to
have a villain net and and I've used OneNote as
a negative throughout this because I think a one
note villain doesn't typically work but I think
when you're dealing with someone that's mindlessly
devoted having this note when you've got the
cacophony of insanity that is the Guardians of
the Galaxy does work in this case you've got one
focal point don't have to spend a lot of time on
them I've always said that team movies won't work
in one movie I was wrong Guardian showed me you
can do a team movie in one movie but because of
their centralized focus on one villain you're
able to have the team be the Forefront so Ronan
works for me better than most but he's not higher
than 38 because I'm like okay that's that guy does
cool he accuses tight and that's that's the whole
journey but dance off little extra points running
the accused all right we're into the top half
we're almost to the top half we're at number 36.
this is probably the one that's going to get me
a lot of crap from a certain audience and it's uh
because I think that people don't unless they're
on the other side of it realize how much of a
problem this is and that is just being a dick
on the internet I'm going with Intelligentsia as
number 36. I think that what they were able to
do with Todd hulkin intelligence is fascinating
I do feel like I would have loved to have seen
the ramifications a bit longer I would have liked
if intelligencia was introduced a little sooner
revealed a little sooner and there was a lot more
than just like we're taking Todd Hulk to jail I
wanted more of the consequences of the trolling
because I think this show is about shining a
light on cockroaches showing people how shitty
they are and I wish there were ramifications to
that because I think that's what those people
need to see so it's lower because I love the
execution up until it was like and we're wrapped
so Intelligentsia is our most real threat there
are people being absolute monsters people on the
internet and that causes real mental and physical
harm so I think that's something that needs to be
addressed so therefore this villain is absolutely
the most realistic villain but I wish there were
more consequences shown so it's on the Lower Side
number 35 is abomination I think that this is
a character that if introduced in Thunderbolts
again could go higher as well Thunderbolt Ross
because I love the idea of a super soldier that's
just listening to order has gone awry that is
touched on a winter soldier but it's touched on
in a different way with abomination I think
Abomination getting even the comedic use of
him being a guy just following orders but they
didn't Shield it opens up a lot of interesting
conversations add to that they fixed the visuals
that made him feel like the Abomination add to
that the fact that I think Emile Blonsky is
a fascinating character now and the fact that
they're bringing him back from 2008 there's a lot
that makes me put Abomination higher than I think
a lot of people would but he's now someone I'm
fascinated to see more of so he's got to be in
the top half Abomination number 34 is arnim Zola I
love that one of the silliest characters in comics
one of the most visually Preposterous characters
worked I love the fact that he represents that
like Tech threat back in the Cold War era and
that Toby Jones was able to be physically in
First Avenger and then a voice that is threatening
and actually causes problems for Captain America
in Winter Soldier Winter Soldier juggles so many
incredible villains very well Gotta Give arnham
Zola some love he's shockingly high at 34. number
33 is varusa varissa I'm try to say it but she
is so captivating so immediately in werewolf by
night this is a performance-based love this is an
actress that came and knew exactly the assignment
acted her eyeballs out made me hate her but be
captivated by her I hated how she treated her her
husband even in death that weird admiration and
logging should have felt I don't know I felt gross
but also that was captivating the way she treated
Elsa Bloodstone she did everything right and you
wanted to hate her and she also felt like a 20s
classic monster movie villain it was so big but it
didn't feel absurdist because it was intentionally
everything everything worked for me love this
villain verusa just it's up there man that was
a great portrayal number 32 door Mamu we're in the
top half pretty steady now we're approaching the
top third this is a villain who is so so hard to
capture because of the abstract this is literally
a concept and the visual Scott Derrickson was
able to bring the feeling of Doctor Strange
just trapping this this concept in a Time Loop
this this feeling of purgatory the pair paranoia
that was able to be captured with dormammu I
absolutely adore mom was a nearly impossible
character to convey and I think they did it I
think those visuals are still amongst my favorite
in the MCU is just the sheer psychedelic trip of
what dormammu as a Visage would have to be and
visited Visage anyway I love love that but I don't
love that the existential threat hasn't come back
if dormammu got to play some more if he got to be
more of a Thanos element if there got to be more
dealing with you know something that had to give
up but like was ruining the day for Doctor Strange
I want dormama to be back as a threat then he'd
be higher but for now that's where door Mama lies
31 and one of my probably more controversial picks
but uh this is where the Deviant slash Crow reside
I think a lot of people didn't enjoy Crow which
was Bill Skarsgard in the eternals but for me the
deviants represented us as humans they were seen
as primitive they were seen as not intelligent
and you realize that the villains the eternals
were fighting were actually just things trying to
survive and they kind of became in our eye line
and I love that because this is a movie about
humanity and then there's a Twist that humanity
is represented by the villains and that the people
we're rooting for might not be the heroes at all
the end of eternals is them sacrificing billions
of lives for the lives they know and they like and
that kind of makes them the villains but on the
journey there you need someone to identify with so
having a Twist of being like I identify with these
deviants I identify with these creatures that are
smarter than we think we are it kind of feels like
how I think we would experience aliens if aliens
can travel interdimensionally they're probably
smarter than us because spoiler alert we can't and
I think that they would see us as primitive so I
identified a lot with the deviants so they're
pretty high up here considering how much that
movie juggled 31 number 30 in our most successful
religious zealot character Arthur Harrow Arthur
Harrow was captivating because Ethan Hawke was
acting his eyeballs out opposite his buddy Oscar
Isaac and I think without that performance the
movie movie I think without that performance
the show that was already juggling a lot of
Mythos and mythology and juggling a lot of
things would have fallen apart I don't love the
final episode of the show Moon night because I
feel like it went to The Punchy kicky problem
that she helped and addressed ironically but
what I was loving was Arthur Harrow manipulating
Moon Knight so up until it became this big smash
you know Transformers s Godzilla thing what I was
focused on was the villain and that that's because
of Arthur Harrow that's because of the performance
so he's really high up there for me and I think if
the show landed differently or if it if season
two balances out in a different way I just love
the fact that when you walk around you hear that
that glass in his shoes and you believed it I love
this show opens with Arthur Harrow punishing
himself I love that his belief was so strong
you believed it it's a fascinating portrayal got a
lot out of this villain Arthur Harrell 29 is Ghost
I'm one of the people that liked Ant-Man and the
WASP more than the first Ant-Man because I really
was captivated by the villain I thought ghost was
very interesting in that she just wanted to figure
things out she was so Earnest in it but then there
was a maliciousness to it I also like that Ant-Man
is a tech based hero and there was a tech based
villain in a non-linear way it wasn't like Yellow
Jacket where it was just evil Ant-Man there was a
different element of tech I do think we're gonna
be more endeared to this villain even more after
Thunderbolts I think there's a reason she is in
Thunderbolts ghost intrigued me I thought it was a
step up from the comic counterpart very intrigued
by seeing more soon number 28 batroc the leaper
yes batroc this is legit one of my moments when
I was like the MCU can do anything not only is
batroc the leaper one of the most Preposterous
comic book characters that shouldn't work on
screen not only did they give him a comic book
accurate costume not only did he leap willy-nilly
to and fro in Winter Soldier and it somehow worked
that his power sets translated on screen but
they cast George Saint Pierre one of my all-time
favorite MMA fighters and it worked like he is a
French man named George so is batroc the leaper
there's just so much about this that works for
me it's such a fun casting Choice used very well
and he leaps and when he comes back in Falcon the
Winter Soldier that was one of the most exciting
moments for me I love batchrock the leaper he'd
be high higher if I had no Integrity if I was
like yo this list about my favorite's number
one bedroom but I'm not that guy we're gonna
get to the top 27 it's gonna take a long time and
backrock the Libra because I respect him I love
him thank you George number 27 I am torn about
this choice because I love this character so much
in the comic books I don't know if it clouds my
experience of this character in the movies I love
Hugo weaving I also love what they were able to
do going forward with the character by bringing
him back even though he had disappeared in in
game there's a lot I like about Red Skull but I
don't remember a lot of red skull moments when I
think about First Avenger that's not a good sign
I think of red skull as this very ominous almost
Dr Doom as presence and since Hugo weaving only
wanted to do the one movie Ross Marquand crushed
it coming back I would love to see more of Ross
Marquand as Red Skull but since Hugo only did
the one and then it was like 10 15 years later
when Ross came back as Red Skull I just can't
put him higher but I think so positively of The
Red Skull I think they nailed it as far as being
the antithesis of Captain America without being
directly linear a lot worked but it can't be
higher than where he's at Red Skull number 26 and
this list was made in honor of the final feature
film in phase four is Namor Namor is probably
the most interesting duality of adaptation versus
translation on this list that in wakanda forever
I'm not going to give spoilers just in case but in
wakanda Forever Namor is incredible at serving the
purpose that Namor the movie adaptation needs to
to make the movie work but name or the comic book
character doesn't feel like Namor in the movie
to me I think of Namor first word I think of his
arrogant and I didn't feel that with this name or
to the level I felt I needed to I didn't feel the
Swarm I didn't feel Neymar was likable and Namor
to me is someone that you're like really soon
Namor and then you're like well I guess I kind of
get it in a bad boy sort of way and I just never
felt that way I feel like Sue storm loving name
or works too logically with this take his kindness
his leadership a lot of things about what made it
work and wakanda forever are actually a detriment
to the adaptation but this is the MCU villain list
as a villain in the MCU incredible as a villain in
the MCU he served the movie's narrative and he
made me feel all the things the movie was trying
to make me feel so like I said this is literally
the hardest one because as an adaptation for film
great delivery of a villain in wakanda forever
as an adaptation of Namor not how I perceive the
character but these are archetypal characters so
maybe my perception and Ryan coogler's perception
are just different so I can't fault him for that
so I really don't know where to put anymore so
for me Namor is 26 he's in the top third ish
because I really like what he was in the movie
but at no point did I go that's who I've read for
30 years Neymar and what a turn to go from Namor
one of the leads of wakanda forever too one of my
favorite obscure c-list characters that I thought
was handled wonderfully shocker that's right look
at your villains list all over the Internet Where
Are You Gonna See Namor followed by shocker right
here that's where I love that not only do we get
shocker as a henchman in Spider-Man homecoming
but he was so quickly replaced I love that we
got two Shockers I love shocker in the comic
books and I think the way to show his like
Ridiculousness is having him played both by Tom
Hardy and by Bokeem Woodbine I love that we got
the experience of Bokeem getting to take on the
mantle and that like I'm gonna do what I need
to for money kind of character really worked
and I felt intimidated very briefly by shocker
but I also felt like a guy that just got these
gauntlets that he's going through stuff I love
the origin I love how they tied in the shitari
I love how it worked with vulture this felt like
the exact right way to use a henchman character
that's why it's so high up in this not only do
I love Shocker the comic character I love this
use of henchmen number 24 probably lower than a
lot of people on their list but that's because of
my experience of her throughout the MCU as well
of my experience of her with the comic books
Wanda maximoff is 24. if Wanda was introduced
as the Scarlet Witch just in Doctor Strange the
Multiverse event somehow I would have liked this
character a lot more unfortunately this character
felt like it wasn't the Wanda we had just left in
one division to me it's like we got 10 years of
giving us steps one through one through seven
and then this movie jumped to ten I needed eight
and nine to get to the Scarlet Witch I did not
feel like we were with Scarlet Witch yet so when
she suddenly literally turns around and black and
white goes to color and evil is there it felt
way too rushed for me personally I also felt
that she could manipulate reality and a couple
times she used her powers to go like pew pew pew
and like make finger guns instead of like doing
cool like there's a moment in the movie where
she like Whispers in a guy's ear and it causes
this this beautiful chaos that to me is Wanda
which is why it's as high as it is 24 is pretty
high in the villain list because I love Lizzie
Olson's commitment I love Lizzie Olson's Scarlet
Witch and Wanda I love her portrayal and I love
most of what they were able to do unfortunately
that leap puts it lower as well as some of the
more linear choices with powers after she'd been
developing them for so long I want this character
to be higher I want wanted to come back I want to
fear the Scarlet Witch more and I want it to feel
earned number 23 is Gore I almost switched these
two and I juggled that for a while but I think I
had lower expectations of Gore because I hadn't
met him yet and Wanda expectations for delivery
and my experiences wanted to throw out one
Division and earlier very high expectations Gore
I just wanted him to be intimidating and scary and
Christian Bale certainly was I wanted Christian
Bale to convey that malice I wanted to believe
his hatred of gods I loved that we had in his
opening scene so much earnest pathos I love that
this movie is as high as it is for me the more
I think about love and thunder the more it falls
down the rankings but the things that work for me
are how much the gods are arrogant and worthy of
the scorn that they get and I love at the end of
the movie what happens with Thor for him to become
a father none of that works without Gore if Gore
doesn't have the emotion towards his daughter if
he doesn't do everything he does for love and he
doesn't have this feeling towards God's none of
that works so Gore works as a villain in this
narrative however it can't be be any higher
because he butchers zero Gods on camera I saw
Zero butchering stabs a guy but there's no they do
all the butchering off camera so he's intimidating
when you see him but I wanted like 20 more minutes
of him so he can't be higher than where he is but
with the screen time we got I was impressed at
how much I felt for eternity and for the gore we
did get number 22 now admittedly this one is high
because it was our first villain and I gotta say
I can't shake off how cool that was Iron Monger
is I think one of the better okay the villain
is the bad the villain is the good guy but bad I
think Iron Monger is a great example of corporate
greed personified and I love the duality of that
because that's basically Tony's Arc he goes from
a war profiteer to a hero that stops war and I
love that Iron Monger is if he never did that Iron
Monger is the guy that keeps profiting Iron Monger
is the guy that steals and makes his own suit and
yes it is the linear bad guy but good good guy but
bad but it works because Jeff Bridges is charming
it was it was our first time really seeing Jeff
Bridges that way in in this big of a movie he's
the dude he's this this awesome loving guy and I
loved his villainous portrayal some of the lines
and deliveries and the way he's intimidating to
Pepper and all those things really work and yes
it's the first movie so there's a lot of love for
where this kicks off Iron Man is still I think one
of the best MCU movies all these 15 years later
and I think without Obadiah stain it would not
have worked as well I could easily see people not
loving this villain as much but for me it's a very
important kickoff to the whole MCU number 21 ego
The Living Planet one I'm very happy just to say
that sentence how crazy is it we live in a world
where ego The Living Planet is in a movie then
how crazy is it that it's played by Kurt Russell
and then how crazy is it that it's a metaphor for
Parental failings for arrogance for Gods and Men
for what it means to be a father to juxtapose what
it means to have a son versus be a father opposite
uh Mary Poppins y'all yondu I love that this is a
movie of Father and Sons and that the father is
ego it adds a Celestial element it adds a human
element with how much Kurt Russell is so invested
in this character I love his relationship with
Chris Pratt this movie falls apart without Kurt
Russell's portrayal of ego and it ends insanely
and bombastically and big I think ego The Living
Planet is a shockingly good villain especially
with how much Kurt Russell is invested in the
fatherhood elements this this worked for me in
a lot of ways top 20 we've got Ulysses S claw Andy
Circus is introduced in Ultron and immediately you
can smell how sleazy this character is this
character is just ripping and dripping with
disgust he is a mercenary that will do anything
for a dollar he's stealing from the wakandans he's
the only guy to get vibranium out because he knows
all the worst people you know that immediately not
only does he deliver that on screen in seconds but
then you get to actually invest in him you care
weirdly about his exploits you don't like him but
you care and that's Andy circus's charm he's such
an incredible performer that South African accent
is impeccable the way he's able to be smarmy but
fascinating you lean into this performance there's
so much going right and it's a character that has
a freaking Sonic Cannon for an arm it is a
character I did not care that much about in
the comic books and Andy Circus made it so much
more interesting and worked in both the Ultron
needs as well as the the Black Panther movie needs
he served his purpose in both and I was generally
shocked when he died love Andy circus's take on
claw number 19 the return and no way home of Dr
Otto Octavius a lot of people's favorite comic
book movie is Spider-Man 2. I personally am much
more Andrew Garfield Spider-Man than Toby McGuire
Spider-Man but I can also still acknowledge how
important the relationship between Toby Maguire
and Alfred Molina's Dock and Spider-Man is in
Spider-Man 2. that is one of the most mature
villain hero relationships we've seen that's
one of the most mature villainous portrayals
we've seen so to have him come back to have
those moments of like Peter it's good to see
you my boy to have him get to go full evil as
manipulated by the chip and get to see Tom Holland
use science to solve problems to see a scientist
rescue them to see him go good and you get to
play around with a lot of like what corruption is
as portrayed by an actor Alfred Molina Nails this
comeback performance dakak is still an incredible
villain in this I really enjoyed the duality of
his performance and I loved seeing him come back
and get to play around with that again doc Ox up
there number 18 Ultron from Age of Ultron I love
this because it's it's a beautiful continuation
of the Tony Stark Arc you've got War prophets
here Tony Stark you've got a man who believes that
he is absolutely correct that then over corrects
and tries to protect the entire planet by putting
a shell around it he puts a shell around his world
he ends up putting a shell around individuals that
he loves by making a suit for pepper by making a
suit for Spider-Man you know by taking care of his
daughter like he ends up accomplishing this goal
in a metaphorical way but Tony's always trying to
protect Everyone by putting a shell around it and
Ultron is that concept gone awry he takes over the
Internet he sees the corruption of man he he has
some logic in his belief that you know humans
are a problem a virus you look at the Matrix
and other things that are a commentary in humanity
Ultron does all that unfortunately and I love the
delivery the voice and everything is so incredible
it's a one-of-one audio experience variants but I
did feel that it wasn't an age of Ultron like the
movie was like you know the weekend of Ultron like
I didn't feel the scope at any point and to me
I know a lot of people have retroactively found
a lot of love for Age of Ultron to me it was one
of the first uh too big a bite like there's a lot
in that movie that's a lot of empty threads
that then luckily with 10 years were able to
come back together but I feel like that quilt
unraveled we've had to sew it back together and
a lot of that was the overly ambitious goal which
I respect ambition but it didn't feel like Ultron
got to be the Age of Ultron we wanted because of
the other things they were trying to do I wanted
to live in the malice of Ultron more and instead
of getting the age I got the weekend of Ultron but
the character himself excellent villain number 17
Supreme Ultra yes the what if Ultron I think just
edges out Ultron because he felt like the Ultron
from the comic books I wanted Ultron 2 but he
wouldn't work without the Ultron from the movies
that said when he takes out Thanos when he does
all those things that's Ultron Ultron should be
an absolutely shaking Force to the entire universe
Ultron should affect everything and I feel like
this did I feel like the Ultron we got him what if
was the the comic panel come to life brilliantly
delivered very investing very fascinating though
I'll acknowledge that it wouldn't it's it's a it's
a yes and it's an alley-oop it's a continuation of
so it can't be higher even though I think it's an
incredible villain because you need the foundation
to get there so it's like a sequel villain in its
own way but Supreme Ultron absolutely decadent
great villain for what if number 16 US agent
we've talked a lot in this list because it's a
very common thread in comic books of hero villain
Duality I think Captain America uh his his anti is
Red Skull right it's like Batman and the Joker
it's not about an evil Batman it's about Batman
has one rule and it is you know not to kill Joker
is about breaking rules and Chaos they're not Yin
and Yang in a direct way they're more about like
conceptually yin and yang I love that us agent is
a direct antithesis not like the Red Skull he's
literally a guy that thinks he's right he's a
guy that believes in a very different America I to
briefly get political worry that there are people
that see America the way that U.S agent does I
worry that U.S agent is a logical choice for a
lot of people I worry that the beliefs of this
character are founded in reality and that makes
them a fascinating character Chris Evans as
Captain America is amazing because he made a
character that is spangled work he legitimized a
ridiculous character so well U.S agent takes that
a step further and makes a scary reality flesh he
makes all the good that is what American Beekman
Captain America I love winter soldier being a
commentary and it's not just answering rules
and just following blindly the US agent does
he just says yes I cannot wait to see him in
Thunderbolt I cannot wait to see where things go
while being afraid of how real he is I think he's
an excellent villain excited to see more from him
also brilliantly betrayed by Wyatt Russell who's
the son of Kurt Russell ego playing a dad and his
son playing a US agent that's just fun that's just
nice I like that irony number 15 top 15 you
lovelies this is probably the most prophetic
villain in the greater MCU this is a villain that
I think we're gonna have actual problems with this
very soon it is a villain that is portrayed by
an actor who is both movie star and like giant
theater nerd and only that man can portray this
character Mysterio shouldn't work Jake Gyllenhaal
just happens to be like this awesome theater nerd
who's so cool so like you've got a theater nerd
character that is charming and charismatic that's
Mysterio you've got someone you want to follow in
this iteration you don't follow Quentin back
in the comic books but in this one they make
him this likable Avenger basically you make him
someone that like you want to be a hero so so
Peter realizes that and and falls apart because
he wanted to like this guy he wanted to like
have that parental figure he's the big brother he
doesn't have Uncle Ben in this universe he's got
this big brother he lost Tony he's weak he needs
that figure that's perfect for Jake chillenhaal
that's that makes so much sense and then on top of
that his powers are what I'm worried about we've
got you know uh deep fakes around the corner to be
not be able to be you know discerned from reality
we've got voice modulation that is already scarily
accurate we won't know in the next 20 years what's
real and what's fake and Mysterio plays with
that that paranoia is coming I love that this
is a villain that's prophetic but I hate the
fact that it's going to be true soon [Laughter]
you're not scared of that [__] terrified
Greg [__] terrified it's coming
this is our last election where we know who's
running we don't know what's coming Greg we don't
know number 14 and probably my most controversial
pick this is a Twist I adored that so many hated
they actually disliked the movie for it you've
got iconography in the world that's what comic
books are they're archetypal characters shown
of beautiful iconography to make us feel things
manipulating iconography itself to use as a
villain that is in fact a shell is genius Trevor
Slattery as the Mandarin is inspired because it
plays with our expectations and that's what the
world is expectations of iconography I love that
he's a man that's branded with all this stuff to
make you think he's this despot this terrorist
and he's an actor I thought that was so clever I
thought it was so well done to Serbia and Kingsley
I enjoyed that twist so very much I thought it was
a way to handle a very difficult character you'll
notice the real Mandarin has not been listed yet
because I love that then they alley-oop that with
a way to fix a certain racial stereotype in a
fascinating way but Ben Kingsley as the Mandarin
is one of my favorite twists and so many things
had to go right to get there I love me some Iron
Man 3 love me the Mandarin number 13 and very high
on the list because the performance is immaculate
if you've got a bunch of people auditioning for
Iron Man and you're like man this guy is so close
to perfect where can we use them we should make
him the ID to Tony Stark's ego and that is saying
a lot because that person's Gotta Dance they gotta
do a lot they got to be a gun profiteer they gotta
have orange hands they gotta be Justin Hammer Sam
Rockwell and Iron Man 2 is one of the biggest
redeeming Graces of that film to the point where
I hope he's in armor War so badly I want him
in armor award so much it's one of my favorite
Lost characters in the MCU he is such a great
elseworld alternate Iron Man he's so perfect and
the whole time you hate how much you love him that
is such a fun villain he's such a piece of crap I
want more of them I hate that I love him give me
more Justin Hammer top 12 you lovelies we've got
someone that was the villain all along another
great twist it was Agatha all along this is a
comedic horror fine character this is such a great
performance by Catherine Hahn I was so impressed
at how captivated I was how I was like second
guessing myself like is she gonna be I literally
thought they might have changed the narrative
to make her not the villain and then of course
she was of course she was they got me and I love
that I love the use of the Salem Witch Trials as
someone from Massachusetts I'll own my bias there
I love that they were able to make her magic feel
like a different element they opened up a whole
new world I love the musical reveal I love how
charming and interesting she was and how much you
want to be Agatha's friend and then how terrifying
she was as a witch I cannot wait for House of
Harkness I was so impressed by this entire take
on Agatha a character that did not get the time
to shine nearly as much in the comic books great
villain number 12. number 11 is playing on
expectations of the audience in a really fun
way you've got an Espionage Thriller and you cast
Robert Redford you're going like oh yeah he's the
guy he's the guy running things he's the guy
like making it work he's the leader he's the
villain because you follow him he's the villain
because of audience expectations he's the guy that
leave so much in his cause that he obviously
doesn't see himself as the villain but when he's
the head of something as big of Shield that's what
you don't expect I love the Hydra Shield twist
so much and it doesn't work unless you've got
someone like Alexander Pierce played by someone
like Robert Redford it seems like such a small
part in the greater tapestry of the MCU but if
you look at where we are now in the MCU it's about
heroes falling apart mentally physically they're
they're so overrun and that all really kicked
off with our lack of systems when systems started
falling apart and winter soldier that quickly led
to Civil War which quickly led to Infinity where
everything Cascades from this moment so a human in
Alexander Pierce causing this is so wonderful and
it's just his conviction and thinking he's right
and to some people he is fascinating character I
would never think looking at all of these names
from Comics I love Alexander Pierce would be in
the top 12 but absolutely was thanks in part to
Robert Redford top 10 you lovelies and the human
that caused Civil War I love Baron Zemo so much
because Civil War is the first time we got that
double page spread comic book moment we got that
insane airport fight scene that did so much for
comic movies and that was all orchestrated by one
man pitting Heroes against each other one man with
a vendetta that honestly like he was a man that
lost his family and nothing he did is redeemable
nothing but you still go man he lost his family
you hurt for him just enough to go man that's
interesting Daniel Brule brought so much Humanity
to Baron Zemo a character that literally in the
comics is dumb enough to get his mask glued to his
face that seriously hit the heat his mask is glued
to his face that's real this is not that this is
a captivating fascinating man with conviction and
evil in his heart because he's hurt and then you
get to play with that further in Falcon Winter
Soldier where admittedly little two buddy buddy I
get why I work for the narrative but I love that
you're captivated by this man dancing the only
trailer they needed for that show was Daniel
Brule dancing that's Baron Zemo dancing in a club
in madraport the fact that the sentence I just
said is real Daniel Brule as Baron Zim dancing
in a club in Mad report that's real life that's
the comic World we're living in because of how
good he was in Civil War love this villain love
to see more of them hoping it's in Thunderbolts
big Baron Zemo fan number nine is The Great and
Wonderful Kate Blanchette as hella this character
is so impossibly captivating you're both intrigued
by what she's gonna do next in a very jokery Loki
way you're both captivated by her origin and that
you're like well she did gotta get screwed over
by the gods which is kind of what the gods do
you're also like God damn is that an attractive
black tracksuit with green stuff that's so like
Slither is sexy everything about this taking the
character is so much I love that the Asgard movies
aren't my favorite but the asgardians are the most
fascinating to me I love what Loki does I love
what Hela does I love the Journey of Mythology
with these characters and she literally did the
thing that broke Thor somehow more than losing
his family she took away asgum she destroyed
Asgard she caused stakes in the MCU she caused
ramifications in the MCU she caused us to know
anything was possible by destroying Asgard through
Ragnarok incredible villain incredible portrayal
wish we got more number eight is a villain we've
met once number eight is a villain we're about to
meet a myriad of times in different forms number
eight is a man who basically monologued at us and
gave us more Exposition than maybe any other
villain in a 40-minute window he who remains
shouldn't work it is Kang but not Kang it's a
preview of what's to comment about to be our
big villain without giving anything away it is a
concept of the Multiverse personified while being
a Shakespearean delivery by Jonathan majors in
such a Powerhouse performance that made Loki my
number one show because in my opinion it's the
one that stuck The Landing the most because of
Keck UT's Kang throughout this show you better
deliver and then it's a monologue instead of a
fist fight and it's one that gives you set up
for the entire phase five six and Beyond also
it's a scene that largely takes place in a room
that has ramifications for the entire MCU that
there's moments that are still trickling out from
this is a crazy ambitious take and they nailed it
I love he who remains slash Kang we haven't even
met Kang yet that's crazy I'm so excited love this
character number seven is my second favorite MCU
movie title character dramatic pause for no reason
the Winter Soldier is everything right about
when you make a movie and trust your audience
the winner soldier was a new character to comic
books you you ask any comic fan pre-2015 if we're
gonna see Bucky come back you doubt it like he
was Uncle Ben Bucky's dead Bucky stays dead Ed
Brubaker brought back Bucky as the Winter Soldier
and it was shocking but I never thought we'd see
it come to screen and it wasn't that long
later it was a newish comic book and then
it was exactly right it played with all of our
emotion towards Steve it played with all of our
love for Sebastian Stan's take on Bucky and it did
it with some of the best action to this day in the
MCU it made you care about little details like the
fact that he was trying to remember and he bought
plums which are good for brain health it had every
little detailed nuance and at no point did it slow
down it trusted the audience to be like plums ha
it's funny if you know and you Google it or it
trusted you to you know recognize that the energy
in the chase scene with black panther and Captain
America would be their different Power sets it
was like when you're a kid on the playground you
dump out all your toys there's so many moments in
this movie that hinge on Winter Soldier being so
awesome you want to know how this fight goes he
is incredible and has only gotten better but he
started as a villain so he makes this list because
he still has villainous Tendencies he's still
working through stuff I'm very curious how they
handled in Thunderbolts Winter Soldier I think
was one of the first times I went this couldn't
be for anyone not just comic fans because of the
Nuance of this villainous portrayal number six
we're getting up there y'all is Mandarin as in
the father of Shang Chi the real wielder of the
ten rings I love this care character because he's
in love I love this character because I felt
for him like I'm not a father but as a father
as a human I felt for what he wanted I felt his
grief and his Justified lust for power in so many
ways that he self-justified I felt shung Chi's
Agony towards him I felt what it was to see him
be corrupted by power they did all of this with
an incredible performance by Tony Leung and they
did it in two hours this is an origin movie not
just for Shang Chi but also for an entire universe
and the Mandarin so they're able to bring us a
Twist on a Twist they're able to legitimize a
villain that's very cheesy at times in the comic
books they're able to build an entire world while
shaping it around this man and they're giving us
these 10 Ring which I guarantee are shaping the
greater MCU to come they did all of that and at no
point did this villain feel shortchanged because
every scene he's in is so gratifying and so uh
captivating in a way that you're like filling in
the dots between scenes this villain's incredible
and he fights on a dragon it's us love this movie
top five you lovelies let's get into it first of
the top five is going to be the great Green Goblin
Willem Dafoe got to come back in Spider-Man no way
home and deliver the comic book Norman Osborne you
got to deliver to the comic book Green Goblin got
to deliver all of that Willem Dafoe glory and he
got to be absolutely terrifying you believed
him kicking the crap out of Spider-Man falling
through buildings and smashing like ultimate
Goblin you also believed his malice and that
he thought honestly you're welcome I just killed
Aunt May I just made you the hero he he knows the
origin of his Spider-Man he manipulates reality in
his villainy he literally kills Aunt May causing
the the cascading origin of with great power comes
great responsibility as delivered by the surrogate
Uncle Ben and Andrew Garfield and Toby McGuire
there's so much incredible incredible delivery
here that doesn't work unless Willem Dafoe after
20 years of not playing the character comes back
and just gives it his all he's funny when he's
pocketing Donuts he's terrifying when he's looking
up and snarling back at Peter after getting
hammered in the face he's intimidating when
you genuinely think he killed Toby like there's
just so much right about this villain and the
whole time you don't know what he's gonna do next
and I love the spider's sense because he can sense
something there's just I could rant about the
Green Goblin performance for an hour but we've
probably already been here for an hour this edit's
gonna be 90 minutes this is a feature-length video
but Green Goblin right here magic all right top
four how do you top the Green Goblin you give
me a very very terrifying but subtle performance
where one of the biggest power plays two of the
biggest power plays are dialogue but that doesn't
shortchange the action with your villain and you
do it with a character that I was iffion in the
comic books I've always loved the Green Goblin
he's my big Spider-Man villain it's like Green
Goblin Venom Doc Ock a lot of people have gone
dock Green Goblin's my guy so I didn't have high
expectations when they were like hey Spider-Man
homecoming vulture I was like the vulture really
that's a choice like Adrian tombs is an old bank
robber you have a Twist you give me the age-old
twist of I'm your father you give me the Darth
Vader twist with the girl Peter Parker's dating so
you give me effectively the Green Goblin twist but
even more so it's not hairy it's not his best
friend it's the girl he likes in high school
there's very little of scary in high school than
the girl you likes father except when he's also
the vulture and most of the scenes of Power are
him talking he overpowers Peter across a room by
manipulating him to summon his glider effectively
it's the wings but it's a glider giving you that
Goblin moment but also the vulture moment he
also overpowers him sitting in a car a comic
accurate car by the way which I love just talking
to him with a green stoplight flashing on his face
giving you that green of the vulture that scene
between Spider-Man and vulture Peter Parker and
Adrian tombs is some of the most Spider-Man stuff
I've ever seen and it takes place sitting in a car
the vulture his Origins being built into the MCU
by him vulture Scavenging the chittari tech all
of it being because of Tony Stark you reinvent
a decent villain and make them integral tied to
your universe and then you manipulate them so
fan expectations of Comics this is exactly what
you want out of the villain fans of the comics
are excited because they got a Twist casual fans
get to be excited by new villain and Michael
Keaton gets to act his eyeballs out as another
person with wings top three Gotta Give it to Loki
Loki was number one for years for a reason he is
duplicitous he is fascinating he is charming he
is he is someone you want to like he got his own
show for a reason he's pretty much a good guy now
kinda but you still shouldn't trust him he will
stab you in the back over and over again and you
will still fall for it because he's so Charming
there's a reason Tom Hiddleston as Loki was able
to Captivate the entire Hall age crowd just coming
out in costume there's a reason when he says Neil
people do this is a character that you never know
what's gonna happen next that you don't know why
you want to follow but you will without a doubt
every time you believe in his intentions Because
he believes in his intentions the comic book has
changed because of how much this character works
he's not even the god of lies anymore he's the
god of stories because the comic book is like we
like Loki like it's it's fascinating the impact
this has had and it's able to incorporate classic
Greek myths and it's able to incorate great lots
of other storytelling from other parts of
the MCU Tom hiddleston's take on Loki is is
Shakespearean in scope and nature and what it's
done for genre content villains this is such a
villain top three easy number two and number one
are both interesting in that you can see so much
of where they're coming from both of them are
absolute monsters they're villains but starting
with number two killmonger is fascinating because
so many of his ideals are not only believable but
enacted if you look at t'challa's choices after
we lose killmonger he does some of what killmonger
was suggesting killmonger is trying to feel whole
but he's doing it in every wrong way he's broken
and lashing out and he's he's so fascinating in
that you're like that makes sense for what he's
been through but that's still not okay he's doing
a lot of things a lot of people believe in he's
doing a lot of things that people put in Corners
would do and this is someone that's been abused
his whole life that's been left out in the cold
that's been kicked to the curb you find yourself
going like man does that make sense to me and
it's all delivered immaculately by Michael B
Jordan who's one of the most Charming people on
the planet you're so enamored by him and he's
also a physical Force he's also a physical
equal he's also someone that people follow
for a reason there's a reason it's like Daniel
caluia's character follows him there's there's
so much going on with killmonger and I was so
impressed by the way that the beautiful dialogue
was able to flow just as much as his energy and
fights and just as much as Michael B Jordan's
presence in the room Immaculate villain number
one is the only one that I worry when people say
this they're not being ironic Thanos was right has
become a meme in itself because I would argue that
since Darth Vader or maybe including Darth Vader
this is one of the best Blockbuster villains of
all time if not the best this is a character
that wasn't trying to end life he was trying
to sustain life by ending life his his goal short
term was killing half the universe his goal long
term was making the universe thrive in his own
messed up way and and that is so interesting his
belief structure was his flaw everything else was
theoretically for a greater good in his own mind
that's what a villain is a villain isn't someone
twirling their mustache going like I'm gonna do a
bad thing it's someone being so convinced they're
right they'll do anything this is a villain set up
for movies and movies and movies and movies and
then still over performed he got his own movie
effectively in Infinity War we followed Thanos on
his journey as the Mad Titan we we saw to a point
where he was coming from I joke all the time that
I'm stuck on the 405 in traffic sometimes my pant
Thanos was right that shouldn't be a thought I
have but it is because that is so well portrayed
by Josh Brolin here and I also love that it's
a fully giant you know 12-foot Grimace that I
believe in I believe Thanos when I see him on
screen the special effects are so captivating
the mocap performance is so riveting the reactions
for everyone around him are so invested that I'm
like that's someone on screen Thanos isn't real
obviously but when I'm watching that movie not
only is Thanos real but sometimes I'm like man
what an interesting view of the greater universe
and you need some one of that scope of that scale
of that conviction to be the conclusion of phases
one through three of something so big he set
a very high bar for phases four five and six
I'm very excited to see Kang very excited to
potentially see Doom I'm very excited for all
of what's to come and I think without Thanos
the MCU wouldn't be what it is today and I
think without Thanos comic book movies wouldn't
be what they are today and that I think is the
best MCU villain if not the best villain of all
time that is gonna do it your lovely 63. I'm so
tired 63 villains ranked for your viewing pleasure
please do not get in the comments and be like what
about Fenris the wolf we can't do all of them
but if there's someone I actually excluded that
you consider a big enough villain please do let me
know if there's anything you disagree with please
respectfully let me know if there's any other list
you'd like to see like uh maybe I don't know best
fight scenes or uh most uh loyal adaptations of
characters I don't know you let me know what you
want to see in the comments thank you thank you
thank you please do leave a like please check me
out on take talk if you watched all this video
and you're like this is still interesting you
will love my Tick Tock you specifically because
you've been here a while thank you so much for
being here thank you to the citizens of reject
Nation you are always so warm and welcoming I
appreciate you and thank you to Greg who's
going to edit this for the next 12 years
[Music]